So why did God when he never change uh
make a law like this in the Old
Testament?
Now you want me to answer because you
said God never change make a law like
this. So you're thinking that because
God doesn't change that his commands
remain the same and do not take into
consideration the historical context
situation of his people.
Okay. This is an argument. So I
understand. Okay. No, but let's go with
your look how you define God not
changing. God does not change.
Therefore, his commands cannot change.
So that means God has to ignore the
historical context, the situation that
his people find themselves in. So let's
let's let's let's reason that out. God
had told the Israelites to offer
sacrifices at a specific location
and his shrine, the temple, the
tabernacle. But now the temple's
destroyed. So because God can't change,
he can't do nothing about it. So they
still have to go to that place where the
temple was even though there's no temple
and offer sacrifices. You see how much
sense that makes?
Okay, I I understand. So but why did he
make it in the first place? Well, that's
too easy. What's the context of Israel
in the Old Testament? Too easy, brother.
Come on, think about it. What? Why did
God tell Israel to eat a certain way,
dress a certain way, and act a certain
way?
Did God wanted to separate the Israel
people from the others? You got it. They
were to eat certain way, dress a certain
way, act a certain way, to be separate
and different from the people and stand
out in order to move the people to
inquire why do you eat this way? Why do
you dress this way? Why do you pray this
way? Why do you marry this way? Because
our god is different from your gods.
Okay, I see. So um uh the context in
Acts 11 talks about um that God made it
clean. Acts 10 9-16
and it's not about dietary food. That's
not the context. The context is Jews and
Gentiles. The Jews at that time were
considered clean because of their
relationship with God. But the Gentiles
were considered unclean because they
were steeped in paganism, immorality. So
God is telling Peter in that vision, I'm
going to make all peoples clean through
faith in Jesus. The animals wasn't
referring to food. It was referring to
nations.
Okay. Now, you want the proof? Open up
Acts 10. Open up your Bible.
Yeah, I have it in the um Explorer.
Okay. Now, read Acts 10 verse 28. Acts
10 vers 28. 28
[Music]
Paul Peter before you finish it.
Ludwick. Yeah. Yeah. Before you read,
Peter is going to explain to Cornelius
the meaning of the vision. Acts 10:28.
Mhm. Yeah. Uh and he said unto them, "Ye
know how that it is an unlawful thing
for a man that is a Jew to keep company
or come unto one of another nation. But
God have shued me me that I should not
call any man common or unclean." Where
did God show him not to call any man
common or unclean?
M
in the
where did he show him? Showed me where?
Come on, brother. Rusty. No, it's not
both. Stop trying to make it both.
Because even afterwards, Peter continued
to eat kashut. He continued to observe
the dietary restrictions of Leviticus 11
and Deuteronomy 14 as did the other
Jews. So, it's not both. Rusty, let the
scripture be the scripture. Now, where
did God show Peter? Where did God show
Peter
that you should not call any man
unclean?
Um, I'm a little confused with this.
Maybe you can help me. I'm sorry. What's
the chapter? What happened in that
chapter?
Brother, you mentioned it. You're the
one who mentioned it. Now you're What's
the What's What happened in that
chapter? You're the one who mentioned
it. Yeah. I I was referring to that uh
God showed him a vision where and in
this vision he said what chapter? The
chapter you're reading that's where it
took place. Acts 10. Why do you think I
said acts? Because you you said it was
um chapter 10. I thought it was chapter
11. I'm sorry. Okay. So now you're in
chapter 10. That's where he saw the
vision, right? Yeah. How many times?
Um
I can you do me a favor?
Do me a favor because it's it's
obviously it's been a while you haven't
read so you may not be familiar with it.
Go to Acts 10. I want you to read 9 to
16 first. Okay? Slowly and loudly. Acts
10:es 9- 16. Okay?
On the tomorrow as they went on their
journey and drew nigh unto the city,
Peter went up upon the housetop to pray
about the sixth hour. and he became very
hungry and would have eaten. But while
they made ready, he fell into a trance,
and saw heaven opened, and a certain
vessel descending unto him, as it had
been a great sheet knit at the four
corners, and led down to the earth,
wherein were all manner of four-footed
beasts of the earth, and wild beasts,
and creeping things, and foes of the
air. And there came a voice to him,
"Rise, Peter, kill and eat." But Peter
said, "Not so, Lord, for I have never
eaten anything that is common or
unclean." And the voice spake unto him
again the second time what God have
cleansed that call not faux common. This
was done thrice, and the vessel was
received up again into heaven. So, three
times. Okay. Now, three times, right?
Yeah. Now, what did he say? Do not call.
What did he say in those three visions?
Um, when Peter said, "I have not eaten
anything unclean." Made clean. Okay. No,
no, listen. He go Peter said, "I have
not eat anything unclean."
Right. Yeah. And then what what did God
say? Do not what? Um, call anything.
Call anything unclean. Right. plans that
call not folk common. That's right.
Don't call anything common or unclean.
But now read 28 again.
Okay. And he said unto them, "Ye know
how that it is an unlawful thing for a
man that is a Jew to keep company or
come unto one of another nation. But God
have shed me that I should not call any
man common or unclean." So it is
referring not to food but to men. Ah, so
when did God show him do not call men
common unclean?
When did he show Sorry, can you repeat?
When did God show him do not call any
man common or unclean? Um, in the in in
the vision. So the vision had nothing to
do with food.
Yeah, you got that first point, right?
Mhm. Okay. Okay. But before you move on,
he showed it to him three times, right?
Mhm. Okay. Now go to Acts 10:17 and 20.
See why three times. I know it's late,
but you called me late. That means you
don't like to sleep. You're a night owl.
Um, you said Acts 10 17 to 20. Why three
times? Why did he see it three times?
17-20. Now, while Peter doubted in
himself what this vision which he had
seen should mean, behold, the man which
were sent from Cornelius had made an
inquiry for Simon's house. and stood
before the gate and called and asked
whether Simon which was surnamed Peter
were lodged there. While Peter fought on
the vision, the spirit said unto him,
"Behold, three men seek thee. Arise
therefore, and get thee down, and go
with them doubting nothing, for I have
sent them." Okay. Now, how many men came
to him? Um, three men. Okay. And these
were Gentiles, right?
Uh yeah. And Gentiles, the Jews can't
come into contact with them, right?
Because they would be defiled, they
thought.
Mhm. Uhhuh. I understand. Okay. Now, now
notice who's telling him, "Don't
hesitate. I sent them. You must go with
them." Who's telling him that? The
spirit. Uhhuh. I kissed your head. You
gave me hope for Europe.
You gave me hope for Europe. I said I
like um I said the Lord. Yeah, but isn't
this referring to the Holy Spirit?
Brother, no. Lord can mean father, son,
holy spirit. It can mean the father. It
can mean the son. It can mean the holy
spirit. Which person of the lord?
Um the holy spirit. Okay. Now why I want
you to see it? Because this is one of
the passages that proves to you the holy
spirit speaks. So he's a person and he's
the lord god because he commands the
church what to do because he's the lord
god of the church. Notice he told Peter,
"Go right away. Do not hesitate because
the Holy Spirit is the Lord God of the
church." Because he is one with the
Father and the Son. He's our God. He's
our Lord. He commands the church what to
do and how to do it, when to do it. And
the second thing I wanted you to see,
it's the spirit who brings people to
salvation. Cuz notice what the spirit
said. I brought them to you. Yeah, I
see. Okay. I was a little confused, but
at first I said the Lord and you said
no. So I was a little No, it is the
Lord. But you got to be specific because
we're trinitarians. Which person of the
Lord? So now you learn, what did you
learn? The Holy Spirit. He is the Lord
God of the church. He commands the
church what to do and how to do it, when
to do it. But then also you learn it's
the Holy Spirit who brings you to
salvation. Because Holy Spirit said, "I
brought them to you." You see that?
Yeah. I I understand because um I have
seen also the debate you had with Chris
Lella and now I'm also a trinitarian.
Praise Jesus for you, man. But now
before we move on, I want you to pay
attention to this. The reason why he saw
the vision three times, each of the
vision represented the three men. Is it
making sense now? Uhhuh. Uhhuh. Yeah.
Three gentile men. How many times he
sees the vision? Three times. Each
vision represented these three men
showing Peter by the spirit who let him
see the vision. Three men are coming.
Don't hesitate because now God is going
to make them clean through faith in
Jesus. And you know why also three? Why
also three?
Yeah. So um why also three? Three
because three men. But why also three
times? Yeah. Because the godhood is
three persons. Yeah, baby. It is the
trinity that makes anyone clean. Three
times. Three times. Three persons of the
Godhead and three Gentiles. Because it's
the father, son, holy spirit who makes
anyone clean.
All right, brother. I hope you got that.
What's your other question?